[Music]
here's a story every parent should pay
attention to an alarming new study finds
that lead exposure is still a huge
problem among children in the u.s
between 2018 and 2020 quest diagnostics
tested more than one million children
for lead in their blood all were under
the age of six incredibly about half had
detectable amounts of lead in their
blood that's nearly six hundred thousand
children and get this kids in the
poorest areas of the country were nearly
two and a half times more likely to have
lead in their blood dr john lopez
joining us right now good morning so
what does lead exposure what does that
mean what type of impact does that have
on children well lead is a toxin
especially to the neurological system so
think about you have these developing
brains especially in young kids and it
can affect learning it can affect
behavior it can cause an increase in
adhd and then all sorts of other
problems hearing problems growth
problems um it really is a bad thing
it's a toxin and there's no cure
there's no cure for it once you have
these effects that they're they're
really not reversible you can give
people remedial learning and things like
that and at very high levels you can try
to do chelation therapy to lower the
levels in your blood but no once it
happens it's happened something nature
said stuck out to me that kids in the
poorest areas of the country were nearly
two and a half times more likely why is
it why is it more
why do you see more of it in poorer
areas as opposed to more affluent
sections you know one reason is is the
legacy of lead in these areas you know
the
lead in paint was not outlawed and not
banned until like 1978. you have these
old houses with chipped paint and kids
especially when they're like one or two
they tend to put a lot of things in
their mouth it's in the soil and it's
also in lead pipes as we found out in
flint michigan all right so as parents
are watching right now they're thinking
to themselves okay what are things that
i should look out for what are the main
sources of lead well they're right now
they're in probably the greatest sources
in the lead uh in the chipped paint
that's around you know we have this
legacy of of lead poisoning and it's all
over the place and even though it was
banned in 1978 it's still in these old
houses the lead pipes it's in the soil
it's in all sorts of other places and we
really need to you know get get our act
together and try to remove it but we can
do something about this right
you know we look at the statistics and
it doesn't sound good you we we all know
how you can get it now but can't we fix
this we can fix it so you know first of
all i spoke to dr harvey kaufman of
quest diagnostics he was a co-author and
they actually did the testing and they
found that uh there was lead present in
a little over 50 percent of the samples
which is astounding it's astounding now
it's not a representative samples but
still it's just too many people and you
know the good news is that the number of
the amount of lead in our systems have
come down dramatically like more than 90
percent since lead and gasoline was
removed and in pain over the past 40
years but the fact that it's still
present even in small amounts is not
very good because there is no safe level
so what dr mona hannah attisha told me
last night and remember she's the star
pediatrician from flynn michigan yeah
from flint michigan she exposed the
whole thing and she said you know she's
practically giddy because they're down
to the last few dozens of lead pipes
that need to be removed they know how to
do something about it they're teaching
other places they have remedial things
in the in place and they have a registry
that's following these kids but she said
why do we have to use these kids as
canaries in the coal mine
we know that it's out there there's this
legacy of lead we know where it is and
we should go out and clean it up
beforehand do prevention rather than
reacting to the kids later after they've
already had it and there's really
nothing the kids should be routinely
tested for lead even today in 2021 well
right now it used to be routinely tested
and the cdc stopped doing that about
1997 because they said oh the numbers
are coming down and they didn't i think
realize that even tiny amounts uh are
present as shown in this study so i do
actually think that it should be
routinely uh measured at one and two but
as uh as dr hannah tesha said why wait
till then we shouldn't use them as oh
look at that the levels are up let's do
something about it we know it's out
there we know it's a problem let's do
something about it right now and there
is legislation uh right now pending uh
with the infrastructure bill to remove
the lead pipes and that's nobody knows
how many there are maybe about 10
million there'll be there'll be billions
of dollars to do that but what about dr
phil landrigan who's who revealed all
this in the 70s he's a hero said to me
last night also he said
why not remove the paint chips too it
costs billions of dollars but it's going
to save many more than that john thank
you so much valuable information now if
you want to see
lead exposure a tip sheet from quest
diagnostics go to our website
cbsmornings.com it's also available in
spanish as well as english